foreign
[Music]
to our press conference following the
first day of the European Council we
have just published all the conclusions
of all the items on the agenda and I
give the flow to the present of the
European counts is
capacity foreign
[Music]
they development
is international
Transportation addresses initiative
foreign
[Music]
thank you Mr President Madam president
you have the flu thank you very much
good evening indeed we had a broad range
of topics we discussed and I want to
highlight four topics we talked about
today in the first one is the fight
against climate change the attempt to
limit global warming which we discussed
intensively with Antonio Gutierrez
and indeed the latest ipcc climate
report that was published I think on
Monday this week is a stark reminder of
the progress of global warming
um and it was very clear in this
discussion that we are aware of the fact
that yes the long-term goals are
important but what is even more
important is action now and to
accelerate
good news in a bitter story is that the
European Union is on track you know that
we have our European green deal that's
the overall Vision but we have also our
clear targets uh cast in the climate law
that is fit for 55 that paved the way to
climate neutrality by 20 of 2050
and here we are on track
compared to the figures of the ipcc
we are overshooting that is good and it
is absolutely necessary if in the last
year the global greenhouse gas emissions
have increased by one percent we have
been able last year despite the energy
crisis to decrease our Global greenhouse
gas our globe our greenhouse gas
emissions by minus two and a half
percent
but of course there is a lot of work
ahead of us we have made significant
progress on many of the proposals of fit
for 55 but we need now to agree on the
remaining ones to stay on track
um in this field second point we
discussed with the Secretary General but
also in an extra round was on Ukraine it
was a very good and intense debate
there's one topic that is especially
important to me that is the case of
abducted Ukrainian children
it is a horrible reminder of the darkest
times of our history what's happening
there to deport children
this is a war crime we know today of 16
200 children that have been deported
only 300 have returned so far
and these criminal actions completely
justify the arrest warrants issued by
the ICC
in this field in partnership with the
ukrainians prime minister moravetzky and
I have launched an initiative aiming at
bringing back these children that have
been abducted by Russia
for that we will organize a conference
we are at the very beginning of very
hard work we aim to pull together
International pressure
to take all possible measures to
establish the whereabouts of these
children
and we aim to assist you and bodies and
the relevant International organizations
in obtaining better and more complete
information
on the children who were deported to
Russia and this includes also the
children who were later adopted or
transferred to Russian Foster families
I'm very thankful to the U.N Secretary
General Antonio gutaresh for having
offered the support of the United
Nations agencies because they have of
course a significant experience on this
very difficult topic
of course we will continue to provide
all support we can to Ukraine just this
week we've dispersed a new macro
Financial assistant tranche worth 1.5
billion euros
with that we help keep Ukraine running
while it is defending itself
and we are once again increasing our
military equipment support to Ukraine
and in this context I also welcome the
agreement in the Foreign Affairs Council
on aiming to provide one million rounds
of ammunition to Ukraine within the next
12 months
of course to achieve this we have to
massively ramp up production capacity on
ammunition in Europe
so we have discussed how to move forward
on this as quickly as possible
the commission will come forward with a
legal proposal that allows for the
ramping up of industrial production of
ammunition
this includes for example therefore the
legal proposal is necessary this
includes for example the support from
the EU budget so it is about building
expanding and repurposing manufacturing
facilities and to strengthen the entire
ammunition supply chain to be fast
finally I'd like to stress the great
success of the solidarity Lanes in
enabling Ukraine to export large
quantities of grains and other cultural
agricultural products this is besides
the Black Sea grain initiative the
second big initiative on helping Ukraine
to export its grain
in this context it is important that we
are helping it we discussed that tonight
our Farmers on in the European Union
that have to deal with the market
consequences because a lot of grain is
now coming to the European market and
this has influence on the prices and
therefore those Frontline countries that
are helping the most with the solidarity
Lanes should not suffer them from
disadvantages
as a first step we have mobilized over
56 million euros from the emergency
agricultural Reserve
but this is not enough this was very
clear tonight
therefore I'm grateful to Romania
that did emotion and that's suggested
that we will look into increasing this
amount for the farmers in the Frontline
States
the fourth topic I want to report on is
of course the big topic of Economic and
Industrial competitiveness
Global competition is strong
we have taken major steps to maintain
our head start
and this in a very short amount of time
you all know about the inflation
reduction Act
through the discussions with our
American Partners we have addressed key
concerns
as you know Unleashed electric vehicles
the United States now has agreed that
European car makers get access to the
U.S market and to tax breaks like their
American counterparts
and on critical raw materials that have
been sourced or processed in the
European Union
it's also agreed that they will be
treated in the same way as those sourced
and refined in the United States
we will for that purpose negotiate a
specific agreement to cover this
and the third Point we've agreed with
the United States is a transparency
dialogue about the clean tech subsidies
this is to make sure that our respective
schemes on both sides of the Atlantic
reinforce each other and do not compete
with one another
of course to make our own cleantech
industry Thrive we still have to do
homework here in the European Union
and this is what the green deal
industrial plan is all about
you might recall that at our last Yukon
meeting leaders strongly backed the main
pillars and objectives of the green deal
industrial plan
and therefore two weeks ago the
commission tabled the relevant concrete
legal proposals in particular The Net
Zero industry Act and the critical raw
materials act so the proposals are on
the table they are in line with leaders
conclusions today and now it is up to
the European Parliament and the council
to find a rapid agreement on our
proposals this is the package that
you're well familiar with for the clean
tech industry
now of course competition and
competitiveness is much broader and much
wider and if we zoom out we need to act
on the overall competitiveness and there
we need to act on many different fronts
we discussed all this in depth over many
many hours I want just in a telegram
steal highlight style highlight a few
points very briefly
first we must better harness our single
Market that is also get rid of the still
existing barriers in the single Market
second
um we you've heard it many times but it
is important we need to deepen the
capital markets Union and to complete
the banking Union
this is essential to unlock a vast
amount needed of private Investments
third point of course we also need large
public investment in infrastructure and
in cutting-edge projects
and for that we need sustainable
public finances this is the whole topic
of rules that are fit for this challenge
in other words the reform of our
European economic governance framework
the fourth point that is important is
that we boost our spending on research
and development Innovation is the key to
success
in the single Market
you know that we have the AIM to invest
three percent of the GDP in research and
development
since more than 20 years we're still not
there we've reached 2.3 percent
our main competitors have much higher
investment so I welcome very much the
Swedish presidencies initiative to
discuss an increase of this goal and how
we can get faster and better in
investment in research and development
the fifth Point
um I have already mentioned with the
view on the cleantech industry that is
boosting our resource Independence and
here with a strong view on the critical
raw materials
the sixth point where we have
intensively discussed because it's a
huge topic but way too much to report
today is the topic of skills
skills are the Make It or Break It for
our single market and our economic
success and we have to get better at
having more skilled Personnel for our
single market and finally the seventh
point is the strengthening of the supply
chains with new trade agreements
very briefly at the very end migration
you know that I wrote a letter as
requested by the European Council right
before the European Council where we
have detailed out our activities since
last European Council to tracks The Pact
on Asylum and migration this has to go
its uh way through Parliament and
Council
and the operational measures and here
the focus wasn't is on
first of all working on strengthening
the borders with Bulgaria and turkey
launching two pilots projects on Border
management how we deal at the border
with migrants arriving not only in
Bulgaria but also in Romania and to show
the best practices of Border management
for fast Asylum procedures or return
procedures
we are reinforcing the search and rescue
capacities of North African Partners
this is being complemented by more
efforts in the fight against Smugglers
and we are also working with our Western
Balkan Partners here mainly through
frontex that has now deployed border
guards in the region and finally we're
intensifying the cooperation with third
countries on return I know it's a huge
agenda where I have been reporting on
happy to answer your questions thank you
madam president
Alice you were first
thank you Alice Hancock Financial Times
um a question for you president
Wonderland but potentially for either of
you you mentioned um the climate goals
the importance of 55 do you think
nucleus should be given the same status
as Renewables such as solar and wind in
the net zero industrial transition and
as a result should it benefit from EU
funding
so we are very clear in the net zero
industry ACT first of all it's from
member states to choose the Energy Mix I
think this is very important to repeat
it although it's well known by you
um and nuclear can play a role in our
decarbonization efforts this is
important Under The Net Zero industry
act a wide set of Net Zero Technologies
and this includes cutting-edge nuclear
have access to some simplified rules and
incentives
but only only the Net Zero technologies
that we deem strategic for the future
like solar panels batteries and
electrolyzers for example have access to
the full advantages and benefits so The
Cutting Edge nuclear nuclear
cutting-edge nuclear is in for specific
Fields but not for all
Ansgar you had a question as well
thank you the drum uh German press
agency DPA
um a question to both of you uh in his
address to the leaders president
zielinski has asked for modern Western
fighter jets I would like to know if you
support this demand and do you see a
chance that Ukraine will get modern
Western aircraft soon thank you
you remember that a few weeks ago we had
mentality here in Brussels and he had
the occasion to have many meetings in
the small formats with the leaders you
know to discuss the concrete and
Operational Support that can be
delivered by some of the members says
these are decisions that needs to be
taken by the member states and that's
why I don't intend to express my own
opinion but in general it's not a secret
that we think that Ukraine needs more
support and more military equipment
here too it is a sovereign decision of
the member states and they have to
decide on what to supplier and how to
supply
Christian
hmm
you're telling me questions
um
yes indeed we have 10 packages of
sanctions and an increasing issue is
sanctions circumvention and loopholes
and of course when we apply sanctions
the other side tries everything to avoid
these sanctions and to undermine these
sanctions
and therefore already in the 10th
package were some proposals to
strengthen the implementation of the
sanctions but also to go against the
circumvention and the loopholes we have
nominated the sanctions Envoy who is
traveling to countries where we observe
sanctioned circumventions he has started
his work we're working very intensively
with our G7 Partners to align and to
share information of course also where
we see circumventions we have introduced
the possibility in the 10th package
on listing either personalities or
companies or entities where we see also
in third countries that they circumvent
the sanctions so a bundle of measures
taken already but this is certainly not
enough and therefore the 11th package of
sanctions will also and mainly deal with
the question of circumvention and how we
can
how we can get against it go against it
this last question yes hurry
with Bloomberg two questions please uh
the first one
um did the issue of the combustion
engine band come up during the
discussion what was the tone of the
discussion was there any question
addressed to uh Chancellor Schultz
asking about his last minute change of
heart on this issue on this important
issue and for in particular for
president Wonderland and the lion is uh
she believes that this issue will be
solved in the very near future and also
for president Wonderland we are told
that the U.S is seeking exemptions for
its still an aluminum export for sebum
do you think that this is possible and
if not do you think that it will be uh
possible to reach an agreement on the
global sustainable steel and aluminum by
by October
yes so the combustion engines were no
Topic in the European Council
you of course know that there are talks
between the commission represented by
Executive Vice President Franz
timmermans and his counterpart in
Germany that is the Minister of
transport
uh the negotiations are progressing
this is the will there's the will on
both sides to resolve this topic
and to resolve it within the scope of
the provisional agreement that has been
found between Council and Parliament and
of course this includes the scope of the
provisional agreement technology natural
neutrality
I just wanted to mention that time is of
the essence in this case as this file is
an important pillar of our fit for 55
package
and therefore we intensify the talks and
I'm confident that we soon will find a
good solution
on steel and aluminum here as you know
we have an exemption
um so we had tariffs we have lived at
the tariffs but it's a matter of time
where we have to find a good Global
Solution on that I think it was fall
don't I'm not sure exactly about the
months in which we reached the
final deadline of having lifted
provisionally uh the the tariffs on
steel and aluminum now we are
negotiating and as always in
negotiations we have to wait for the end
then we can report on what the result is
thank you madam president that concludes
our press conference we'll meet again
tomorrow the Euro Summit at 10 A.M